religion is increasingly suppressed
among educated people it's not
suppressed politically or legally but my
students at Yale as a students in in
colleges across the country have no
concept of what the Bible is or what's
in it think of it as a toxic book know
nothing about Christianity less about
Judaism so at the same time when the
threats to human dignity and integrity
are going to be ramped up to
extraordinary levels of stress where we
most need wisdom and moral seriousness
we're seeing wisdom and moral
seriousness come under attack and often
from the same people who want to do the
genetic engineering is crusading
crusading atheism is sort of a cause
today it's popular I don't want to say
among scientists I mean as to to general
and it it isn't so but there are
certainly prominent people in the
scientific community there are prominent
people who were religious Jews or
Christians in the scientific community
but there are also prominent people who
have taken their atheism to the public
successfully who are crusading atheists
who preach atheism atheism in an
aggressive way as a consequence of
science they play on people's weakness
and ignorance and so far as most people
don't take the trouble to learn science
it's easy for a scientist to say I'm
smarter than you are because I know and
you don't you know I understand the
genome and you don't I understand
physics I can do hard calculus problems
and not just 12th grade level ones so
you can see how much smarter I am then
then then you are and when I tell you
there there are no moral absolutes and
religion is trash and furthermore we
ought to go ahead with human cloning we
should go ahead with genetic engineering
and implants of all sorts which will
smudge line between human and machine
we're getting into a moral conflict of
interest which is tremendously dangerous
I I don't think we will succumb I mean I
think you know human beings have faced
hard challenges the second world war was
as difficult a crisis as mankind ever
will face 50 million people died
humanity teetered on the edge state
paganism was was preached aggressively
by Hitler I Germany which despised
Christianity as much as it hated Jews
didn't hate Christians as people but it
hated Christianity the Japanese Empire
which was which revived state paganism
in preference to the more sophisticated
religion of Buddhism and Christianity
that had been popular in Japan Stalinist
Russia which was an aggressively pagan
nation suppressed Christianity that was
a crisis an enormous crisis we rose to
the occasion we defeated it it damaged
us we still bear the scars I think we're
gonna face a crisis in the coming
century there will be different in
character crises never the same we never
see the same crisis twice I know we have
the moral strength to rise to the
occasion and I hope and pray that we do
in practice
[Music]